i have been such a huge fan it's the
understatement of the planet this is a
bucket list moment for me to be able to
talk about all things love home family
being self-taught
but can i start at like word go because
i found something i had never seen
before
and
it really blew my mind
there was a commercial yeah right that
you saw don't give me too much credit
here it wasn't that i saw it every male
in the central texas region saw this
commercial you're referring to and we're
drawn to
moss like flame to uh to this to this
town trying to meet the beautiful and
talented joanna stevens you know what it
was tire technology coming out of those
lips
and eyes and those beautiful eyes those
eyes and those beautiful voluptuous lips
and tire technology
made for
an insatiable
uh
uh they made me say we will not be
undersold a few times because like we
don't believe it so i had to be like
aggressive we will not but it felt so
even watching and i'm like oh my gosh
i'm talking about tires do you mean the
cattle prod of talking points on a daily
basis oh yeah oh if i don't hit that
stuff we all live in that world you're
like flowing yes you're going and
they're like
talking points talking points selling
points talking about that yeah would you
be kind enough to tell us that you will
not be undersold again
yeah exactly
we will not be undersold
i felt that
i felt that yeah
yeah you felt it well done i don't know
why it made me giggle but it was just
because it's like
seeing you this close also i'm just so
delighted i used to have lines but about
we will what did i use to say about the
lug nuts i don't know but that's my
point men and lug nuts yes and sexy
women is a very potent combination
what was date number one like you see
her talking lug nuts
yeah what did you what was your next
move what was the first date what was
the vibe tell me i was i was physically
at the tire shop when i first met chip
and i was walking out as he was walking
in the doors and i just
kind of my personality i just go
straight out the door he's like wait
wait wait you're that girl on the
commercial and right off the bat i roll
my eyes like oh he's one of those guys
she'd heard this a few times turns out i
thought this was an original lie he
turns around and starts following me
and so then i'm taking a break outside
sitting outside so we chat for about an
hour and then he leaves and i think oh
that's a sweet guy it was a great
customer i actually um
went to his and i looked at the system
and wanted to see how much the chip
gains has come to my dad's tire shop so
you basically through your family
computer did a google search
and got receipt yes and was like people
paid for all of his statements his
invoices i was like okay okay so the
first date first date so there's this
little house that was like a um they did
a buffet style home style um
dinner on the weekends and you would go
and it was like this beautiful bed and
breakfast but they would just serve
dinner and we just all i remember is
chip talking i don't think i said maybe
two things because he was just talking
and talking and i was like gosh this guy
knows how to talk and it wasn't like gab
talk talk talk it was just everything he
was saying was so interesting to me and
then
and then chip is playing this game with
his friend that's like hey let's see how
long
i think it was like what were you guys
doing about i picked the wrong girl to
play this game with i will say so
explain the game
long story short you go on a date and
then you play a little game with your
friend and so i was going to see how
long it would take for her to call me
back
but i ran into a brick wall in that
regard months and months go by and my
friend and i are like
what so me and my friends are like oh he
didn't call and they're like would you
call him i was like i'd never call him
no she'll never call him so then i don't
i don't call him and then three months
later
he calls me and he's like okay i'm done
playing these games i'm sitting here
going what game i'm done playing these
games literally came out of my mouth
like that's it let's quit let's quit
jacking around and she was like nobody's
been jacking around what's what's wrong
with you and i was like i've been
waiting on you to call she was like i'm
not calling you so you go what calls we
go on a date that night we go to a
basketball game and then ever since it
was we were engaged in a year later oh
thank god yeah and it started wrong
playing chicken yes
[ __ ] joe if you just picked up the
phone this whole thing would have been a
lot more probably why i never had any
boyfriends because i would never call
any i mean i was so traditional and now
it all makes sense i am too yes i i want
to be a woman
who i want you to pursue me i don't want
to and yet in business
i am
very different yes that's true i'm a
woman in the boardroom and
much more
tentative in the bedroom as a twist on
the mick jagger quote yeah sure um i am
you know funny joe is exactly opposite i
knew this was coming because it's
evolution we want the man to walk into
that cave and say hey she's got your
mind she's got this swing set up in our
bedroom and she just
bounces around like a like i would love
a swing but there's no swing love swings
by magnolia they would smell like
podcasts
that's good you can put it on the front
porch or the bedroom that's amazing um i
mean after 18 years of marriage i think
yes this is the 2.0 we've all been
looking for the spice we were needing
[Music]
you